[Music]
foreign
with President Biden to you know
obviously hear his Direction and what he
said in that call which is what he has
said time and time again is that we you
know we the Chinese people deserve a
good economy and prosperity we have no
interest to hold China down to hold
China back to hold the people down and
no interest in strategic decoupling well
what about us don't Americas deserve a
good economy the bite Administration has
yet to give it to us meanwhile as Laura
said last night it looks like beijing's
bailout is in the works joining us right
now with a different point of view Bob
lighthizer former U.S trade
representative under President Trump and
Robert O'Brien former Trump National
Security adviser with a rich resume for
both of them Bob economically China has
never been more vulnerable so why is it
our job to prop them up uh I'll start
with you Bob lydheiser
well it's it's absolute Insanity Brian I
mean the reality is the status quo more
business more investment helps China we
are transferring hundreds of billions of
dollars of the wealth of us and our jobs
and our children's jobs and wealth to
China every single year we have to stop
that they're using that money to build
up their army their Navy to build their
technology and I was quite disheartened
by this trip because he had said we want
more business we want dialogue look at
dialogues we've had dialogues for 40
years with China they they promise
things and never do anything what it
told me is either that these people
don't understand the nature of the
threat
or they think the investment class is
more important than the working class so
Robert O'Brien you weren't there yet uh
in the position you were in but one of
the first visits that Donald Trump had
was President XI over to Mar-A-Lago
what derailed were you guys were they
wrong to say put your hand out we can
work together then what derailed since
well look I think that Chinese took
advantage of everything we gave them and
every opportunity we gave them and and
Bob lighthizer is the best negotiator in
America and and got a great deal and
then they didn't abide by the deal and
they they breached it and and showed
that they weren't interested in anything
so what they're doing they're taking the
money that we're sending them all the
investment into their shipbuilding
companies all the investment in their
aerospace companies and they're building
a destroyer a month we build two
destroyers a year they're doing one a
month and and they built a thousand new
nuclear silos in in near Beijing they're
gonna have more web icbm's
intercontinental ballistic missiles
pointed in America then we've got
pointed at Russia and and they're using
it with our money we're funding it and
this whole thing's ridiculous it's time
to decouple from China and yeah the
Chinese people deserve Freedom too I
mean that's what Gina raimondo left out
they deserve a good economy but they
deserve Freedom they deserve to be ruled
by people they elect not by the
Communist Party yeah uyghurs deserve to
not live in concentration camps yeah I
thought we were anti-concentration Camp
as a country here's how the Democrats
are spending President Biden's handling
of China watch
where do you think things stand with a
relationship with Beijing what needs to
change the things that need to change
are being changed this Administration
has had the strongest response to
economic competition and National
Security of any we've seen in decades
beginning to hold China accountable in a
way this country has not for too long
is are they Tough Enough Bob I think you
indicated they aren't and here's one
other thing that has changed since you
left China now has 21 at least
unemployment among its youth 18 to 24.
they're good they're economy was growing
at eight percent before the pandemic it
stuck at three and the real estate
companies are imploding after a decade
of overbuilding this is vulnerability
but it also shows a country that it
might look to strike to change the
subject and to change the mindset your
thoughts
well first of all you know the notion
that they were the first people to take
on China is absolutely untrue what we
are seeing as a return to the Biden
policy which is really kind of a protest
a status status quo pro-china kind of a
policy and holding them accountable the
only thing they have done constructive
is keep the Trump tariffs and and and it
scares me to be honest Ron what will
happen if if President Biden is
reelected I believe the tariffs will go
and I think the tariffs are the
beginning of of decoupling it started in
the Trump Administration we were the
first Administration in history to
recognize the gravity of the of of the
of the relationship and and and to
recognize and state that they were
an a hostile adversary
you didn't begin this process of
changing our economic relationship
uh and uh Robert O'Brien just to close
uh we know this the brick Alliance has
formed to counteract I guess uh the the
G8 and the G20 and it consists of
countries like Venezuela Russia China
India maybe even Saudi Arabia
to rival America and devalue the dollar
should we be worried
well we shouldn't be worried now I'm not
too worried about any Alliance that has
uh Argentina and Iran and China
economically but what we we do need to
be concerned about is this appeasement
of China and they're trying to use
bricks to to take away our our advantage
of the world but they they said the Spy
balloon Over America and what was the
response four cabinet secretaries go to
Beijing and Janet Yellen bowed to G and
Romando said she wants to help them you
know bail them out of their economic
crisis when there's you know any bailout
we give them will be used to build more
platforms to to threaten our Sailors
Airmen Marines soldiers Coast Guard men
in the Pacific I mean this is this is
ridiculous the the bite Administration
started out pretty well when they were
following the Trump policies but now
they're going to the old Democratic
Handbook of appeasement of China and
it's really a shame it's a shame and
it's embarrassing we deserve better we
put more money our tax dollars into a
pentagon to show Muscle not weakness and
they hacked raimondo's email and she
still goes over there with a big smile
on her face it's a joke guys thanks so
much for spending your Thursday night
with us appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else